hi I'm Devon ayer que podría and i work
at vote from research I'm the kernel
developer of calculus functions and my
talk is going to be about new features
and calculus and how they relate to the
education and research so we were having
this perfect edel for the last one year
or so and what I'd like to just tell you
what what we have been doing now we've
been doing a few things one is to talk
about a new functionality for integral
equations integral transfer but on the
other hand we've also been working what
about education and other things so much
of what I say today is work done by
others I'll try and decayed but the main
point is this is really work done by
several other people not just myself so
let's begin now and get out left my talk
so on September 27 1990 a student from
sent a suggestion asking us dissolve
should support integral equations and
Amir 26 years later we had done ok so
what took so much time well what took so
much time is because he just couldn't
find a good book to test my
implementation and I did find one last
year it's called a first course in
integral equations by Abdul was well I
think it had four examples I impaired
this whole functionality we got an A+ on
the benchmark so we were done and steven
is very very happy i have seen it so
happy in a long time ok last year victor
adam chick who is one of the original
developers integrate joined us and he
and I worked on these belen transforms
and how current transforms I like to
talk about that and hopefully attractive
elementary but hunger transforms a new
so they don't work in 11-point oh they
probably don't work in your build the
only work in my build if the laptop is
facing north exit for us so this is a
very new piece of implementation so I
warn you this is pretty new around july
2015 stephen sent me an email saying why
don't we have a green's function for pd
0 DS so this time is a bit quicker i
finished up in a few months and now we
have a very nice implementation of
greens functions for differential
equations but you know our heart is
really with the people who do education
because I'm a teacher myself and it
always strikes me that we need to worry
about the people who actually use us day
to day and I make probably 125 students
the last two months at various career
fairs and then I asked him what would
forum do you know her from yes we do it
has saved my life many times by which
they mean that they could submit the
homework on time thanks to some Wolfram
product ok so I think we need to worry
about these people a lot and that's what
we have been doing ok so that's the
outline for my talk and now let's begin
with the inverse having ok I need to go
back all the way sorry pic sorry ok I
need to go ok ok good so I need to go
back a long way ok good so so let's play
with integrity equations and over here
that's a volterra integral equation so
it's got an X in the integral on top and
that's not so difficult to solve it's
almost like an OD so let's solve it and
we solve we'll handle it quite easily
then once you have solved the equation
you want to verify the solution so let's
check the solution and let's plot it and
we are done so now this is the good old
dese already know and love working with
integral equations not just with
differential equations ok so that's the
first theme for entire equations then we
are the fellow McQuillan just slightly
harder to solve so that's a fredholm
equation and the tell-tale sign is that
it's got an integral without an X in it
that's the freedom equation ok so now if
i solve it it's essentially a problem
linear algebra we get a solution and
again we can plot the solution so this
is
as easy as pie now with the new d solve
functionality now historically the first
implementation of this integral
equations was done by algal and I will
work with what is called a total Crone
problem so what's the total gun problem
you're given a curve where you want to
find a curve down which if you throw a
particle from any point it which is a
bottom at exactly the same time so
that's a hard problem but basically it
boils down to solving an integral
equation so okay so that's the other
equation so we solve it the D solve take
just a minute and then I'd seen a really
nice animation of this on Wikipedia so I
didn't out do it I give it to eat I and
eat i spent a long time on it he kept on
telling me i'm going to finish up finish
up it went down sometime he got help
from the developers but finally he did
manage to get a real nice animation so
it's gonna take a bit of time because
it's a hard animation to do but you can
see a way that's a curve under which if
you at any point curve the ball will
fall down exactly the same time okay so
that's the herbal equation okay and
finally we come to the final kinetic
Wayne which is an integral differential
equation so these are integral equations
in which you have a derivative and an
integral now you know maple has got two
functions you've got d solve which does
differential equations and I solved does
integral equations and so they can never
do an integral differential equation so
when I tested it maple I think does
nothing in this area because they don't
know what to do with it so that's an
integral differential equation I solve
it with an initial condition and get
back an answer quite quickly it's not
too bad but it is a hard integration
over here I plot the solutions but now
I'm talking to velocity over here not
the position
as it normally would and then she'll bow
actually showed me how one could go go
about animating this
okay good so one can animate this slight
problem with the animations let me just
go on with the next slide which is to do
with the Mellin transform okay let me
just go back okay so there's no Melon
transform so Victor a workflow in brain
transform so Mellin transform is very
similar to ill applause transform but
except that you have an x rays s minus
one so you see where the answer the
gamma function and in fact gamma
functions play a big role in the million
transforms so here is a table of melon
transforms and you can see there are
Donald's all over and you're done okay
so that's a melon transform table and it
got lots of gammas in it okay so right
so that's the manor transform table and
then when go inverse Mellin transform
it's basically pointed to integral so
let's go on to integral over here and
this example of an investment in
transform and then you get back a plot
of the Bessel function so basically the
Mellin transform is very easy to work
with where it called gamma function the
output okay so let's go on now to relay
convolution okay so many cognition is
just a kind of integral over here so I
try and do an example that's a SAM
current problem which our company
actually won a prize for that smell and
convolution over here and you can check
the answer is integrate in just a minute
sorry about that okay so finally we go
on to the mighty reviews which is a new
function so might reduce will give you
the mise equivalent of any functional
you want and gears vessel and get back
on algae for that and then you can get
back the answer well Bessel function by
just checking activate so here's an
example of a table of module uses so
this is that evil my reduces and the
real expert on this is oleg merc ship
and you should go to malls talk well
Cyrus talk on this topic by oleg for
more details about this topic ok so now
i go on to huncle transforms so hunter
transform is just a better base
transform and you see over here that
that's huncle transform it's based on
the Bessel function luckily the inverse
of the strands storm is just of
transform itself so you know it takes
one line to do it and it could do it
quite quickly ok but in fact a huncle
transform is basically a 2d Fourier
transform ok so here's the idea that you
have a 2d Fourier transform of something
and then what you can do is you can
basically use a huncle transform to
evaluate it so
yep
sorry
okay thanks yeah okay good and you know
I saw a nice gallery of these transforms
in a book on fourier transform back this
way so let us just do that those
transforms over here so let me scroll
down a bit more oh yeah
ok there you ok this is a nice value of
Uncle transformer I can do it just a
minute
[Music]
okay somebody I don't get that but let's
go on out to green functions well too
okay good so George Breen was a baker
basically and you only had one year of
schooling and finally in a deepening aid
he wrote this wonderful paper which made
him famous but basically the greens
function Mathematica is an
implementation of his ideas so here is
an example of an impulsive spawns from
be solve a little green function
actually over here so you can get the
impulse response straightaway over here
and you can call it with let us say unit
step to get the step response
p
they are less in person spawns you can
convert it with a unit step function to
get the step response and may be running
out of time says take up almost slide
which is the most important for me and
that's with poly education so this
summer I had a few interns who came ok
ok so a v8 train Tunes coming over here
to written research and they work with
us to benchmark Stewart textbook on
different on calculus and your sample
notebooks let me show it to you so this
is a notebook on well honey conversation
can you see now it possibly show that
notebook
that's your notebook Lea
okay so basically you're trying to be
temples for limited cetera you have some
examples over here so that's an example
for limit okay and he'll FC was my boss
again sorry
okay thank you sorry okay so here's some
new stuff on B which we working on okay
okay main point we are trying to work on
various nuclear features for example etc
and you should start seeing them in the
bay is very soon okay in the next three
is probably okay so i think i should
just finish up over here and basically a
good friends play more integral
transform any near future we want to
prove documentation and of course we
want to try and implement new thing like
series solutions of differential
equations when we can so i am sorry this
had some problem with the video but i
stopped oh yeah thank you very much
[Applause]